takeaways to this like healthy  restaurant True Food daily right so  we've eat the food it's great the  waitress comes up to us afterwards and  she's all like hey would you guys like  dessert she goes into this cookie story  about well our cookies are chocolate  chip cookies and they are they are  binded together with bananas and it's  vegan gluten-free no sugar the cookies  were nasty as hell it looked like a  cookie but it was smoking mirrors man I  don't want your nasty cookie it's not  the same so stop trying to make me feel  like it's the same well let's take all  these healthy things let's scrunch them  all together and make it look like it's  a real cookie this ain't a real cookie  okay I know what a real cookie tastes  like and I shouldn't be having that  because I'm trying to lose weight so  this thing that's going on all you  making me do is feeling bad that I don't  have a damn real cookie okay so stop it